when a status I I'm Kristen toll and I'm
a director in the Microsoft research
connections team and I'm going to talk
to you a little bit today about doing
community-developed
translation models so presently there
are 7,000 languages in the world over
that that's what experts tell us but
only a hundred of them actually fewer
than a hundred of them are automatically
translated from one language to another
and something that the UN tells us is
that every 14 days another language goes
extinct so what we're trying to do with
the Microsoft translator hub project is
try and stem the tide and be able to
allow people to community source the
creation of translation models in order
to save those languages and preserve
them for generations to come
I thought I'd start out the talk just
covering a little bit of area about how
you can include your community in
developing a machine translation model
but just to give you an overview we have
a lot of different interesting
algorithms statistical algorithms that
actually help us develop a machine
translation model and data is also a
very key important ingredient in order
for us to do that where I'm going to be
focusing this talk today or in some
interesting new develops developments
we've done in this space which are in
domain-specific data and also doing
domain-specific within target languages
and also enabling users to participate
and vote and allow things to show up in
the translator model system through the
community so how the system works is we
take parallel data and that's all I'll
explain that a little bit later about
what parallel data is and we combine
that with data that we have inside of
Microsoft so if a translation model
already exists you can actually tap into
Microsoft's big data and their
translation models by bringing your
small data to bear but this allows you
to actually build a more accurate model
because you're actually able to leverage
the models that we create monolingual
data is data in the language that you
want to be translating from so for
instance if I want to go from Quechua to
span
or I want to go from Mayan actually or
Maya to Spanish what I would do is I
would actually get a lot of data that's
that we're targeting to do if such as
mine these go through a training system
which is supplemented by testing and
tuning set to check for accuracy and
then they feed into our contextual
translation models that we provide well
I'm going to this is a very high-level
architecture diagram I'm going to go
into a more detail on this later so
don't get nervous about this light this
forms are a model weight vector and what
that does is input which can be text
speech video even images goes in one
this creates the decoder that translates
from one language to another and out the
other side you get a translation so I
thought what I do is I show you one of
the early community sources systems that
we have and we've been working at the
Lake Washington School District and that
school district has about 25 or 30
different languages within the school
where children in the home are exposed
to one language but at the schools
they're actually exposed to another
language which is English but it's
important for parents who maybe don't
have English as a first language to
understand what's going on with the
school district so what we've done is
we've collaborated with them to provide
a system that would automatically
translate their page so if you scroll
down in this page you'll actually see at
the bottom that they can translate it
into Spanish and if we do that what we
can do is we can select from there's
actually 37 languages that we support
I've got Mong da selected there because
that's the newest language that we've
supported and it was a community
developed language but what I'm going to
do is actually convert that into Spanish
so now you can see that we actually
convert it over but this isn't something
that we do in a vacuum what we want to
do is we want to get people involved and
I can also translate it back here at the
bottom but what we do is we let people
go into the system and they can actually
improve the translation by going right
clicking on it
and then they can suggest a better
translation if they think that this one
is not appropriate and we've tapped into
the parent community for the children in
the Lake Washington School District to
help us make sure that this page remains
accurate and we incent people by showing
leaderboards like who submits more
translations and others so they kind of
compete together these parents they
compete against one another to submit
translations and make corrections so in
the Lake Washington School District
River and these are the people that
we've tapped to be what we call
community leaders and the largest
portion are actually Spanish we have
more spanish-speaking people in the Lake
Washington School District who are
making corrections to the page and what
we found is that we can show them the
rewards you know get them to compete
against one another but reward them
instantly for their for their
contributions but the most telling thing
that we think is is that none of the
community because they take a personal
pride and the models that were
developing
there's been no spamming and we have no
expectation that there would be this is
something that we were concerned about
but it actually has not happened so even
pages that don't have our little widget
embedded on it we can translate so I'm
running this in Internet Explorer and
all I have to do here is a right-click
on it and you see I get this menu bar
that comes up and says translate with
being and then I get this and I can auto
detect what it is and then which is
Spanish in this case and I can convert
that to English so now you can actually
see that this page has been converted
into English so I'm going to it's a
little bit hard to read at the top so I
decided I'd slide it down a bit so you
can see this is where you can actually
have the settings which are two at the
top of the page you would actually see
that that you can translate it between
Spanish or any other language that we
presently support so what do we do about
these languages these other you know 69
thousand languages at the or 1660 nine
hundred languages that we don't support
what do we do in those cases well what
we do is we tap into the community and I
thought I would actually provide you
with a quote from John Ralston Saul the
the
best way to shut down freedom of speech
is the loss of a language and so it's
very important for us to make sure that
we preserve these languages I was
recently in Nepal running a workshop
trying to preserve the Nepali language
and one of the things that was very
shocking to me we saw these children
playing out in the soccer field and they
were shouting to one another in English
and if you go to school the kids are
actually punished if they speak Nepalese
to one another so at the college level
many of the university students who went
to our workshop were not fluent in the
police and the reason is their parents
believe that it's better for them to
learn English or some other major
language as opposed to speaking Nepalese
so they've literally in-country losing
their own language so it's you know and
there's no way you know hi Mei who's the
chair of this event and I were talking
about this
there's no way to truly express yourself
except in your mother tongue like that's
that's the only way you can really truly
express yourself I mean we can get close
with translations but really what comes
from the heart what comes from inside
has to be in the mother tongue so what
the translator hub does is it enables
companies it enables organizations
language communities educators to build
custom private domain-specific
web-accessible automatic translation
models we literally are enabling people
stepping out of the way
allowing people to build these
translation models themselves when I say
custom that means it could be for any
language even languages that we don't
presently support even pairs of
languages between two languages that we
don't support private means that it
belongs to the community it's developed
in private and when the community feels
like releasing it and deploying it then
it gets deployed it's the the ownership
really lives with the community leader
who signs up to do one of these
languages and web-accessible it runs on
Azure and so it's accessible anywhere in
the world it's a web service that runs
in Azure so when we ran the workshop we
ran it live against the system in Nepal
at Kathmandu with questionable
connectivity but it worked very well
actually for our training event but what
it does is well
Liat empowers users to take a hold of
this it sort of picks it out of the hand
say of a large company it puts it into
the hand of communities and as I say
it's a free web service we don't charge
for you to develop the translation
models and that it leverages as I had
said before you bring your small data if
it's a language that we support you can
tap into our big data models and that
means you get more accuracy more quickly
and we have all kinds of api's and
guides and even how-to videos on the
website to show you how to use it
we support soap Ajax HTTP and OData
interfaces so this is dr. pong yang and
he was one of our alpha testers this is
before even beta these guys really put
us through the paces and trying to
develop Mong da but working with his
community it took about six months
working with his community but they
actually were able to release their
language on bing on an international
Mother languages day which was February
21st of this year so this is a proof
point of a case where a community
developed the model decided as a
community that it was ready to ship and
then they shipped it I mean no
translation model is going to be perfect
not from the outset but the thing is
this language is a living thing and it
changes over time if you give ownership
to the community that language evolves
and so you're continuing to improve it
over time and it's the community itself
that has ownership and pride in what it
is that they develop so we also like to
acknowledge people so since they did the
work we didn't do the work they did the
work what we wanted to do is we wanted
to make sure that people in the world
knew that they did the work so what we
do is off these different language
models that we translate we provide a
place for them to be acknowledged for
their hard work so that people know in
the world that this was done not by
Microsoft but this was done by the Hmong
community and so this is one of the
landing pages that we have there were
currently working on for now police as
well and if you want to read more about
it in Spanish there is a blog that's out
there of course this was written in
English but I use the translator to
convert it to Spanish but you're more
than welcome to go find out more about
that and use the Bing Translator to
convert it
so this is the landing page that people
get sent to and this is an
invitation-only site so you do have to
request an invitation in order to use it
the reason for this is we don't want
just random people sending thing it's
kind of like the Lake Washington School
District we want to make sure that
you're serious about it because this is
actually taking compute time not only on
our web service but the high performance
computing cluster where we build the
statistical training models in order to
have translation models developed so
it's important that we make sure that
people are have a plan what they're
going to try to do and you can do more
than one model once you've been invited
the sky's the limit and I'll show you
how many languages we support and it's
quite easy it's a very easy step-by-step
process and again we have guides that
help you along the way but it's setting
up the project adding your data go to
you know creating the model and then
just going live of course the devil is
in the details so I thought what I would
do is I would show you some screenshots
of that I was going to do a live demo
but unfortunately my internet is up and
down and I thought that would be a
mistake
didn't want to have any technical
difficulties so for instance what I
would do once I've logged into the
system is I would create a project
there's a drop-down up here that says
create project that's selected and so
for this example I thought well let's
let's do the Mayan preservation project
and go to local Yucatan Mayan languages
because there are actually several
groups there's six groups that are
spread geographically across South
America Central America and Mexico so I
picked one actually that's local to this
area which is Maya or moth um and you
can do it to English or you can do it to
many other languages in here we actually
have almost 1300 languages of which you
can select from now earlier I said that
there were 7,000 languages spoken in the
world but those languages are largely
spoken languages they're not text based
so this particular version supports text
but in the case for instance like Hmong
Mong was a language that was also a
spoken language not a written language
so what they did is they developed a
language and it's been around for long
enough 60 years now but they developed a
language to map to that in order to be
able to put it here but for instance I
could golf
I'd said English before but now if I
want maybe I want to go between Maya and
Spanish I can do that here the other
thing that's really interesting and I
said this earlier custom domain specific
models so whenever you're building a
model you know being as a general
purpose model you know you can it can
map to all kinds of things but the
accuracy perhaps is not as high as you
would want if you were doing a very
specific thing like if you were going to
be doing anthropology or if you wanted
you to be doing chemicals what I find
actually a there's been a lot of
interest particularly from the Gates
Foundation is agriculture you know they
want to develop agricultural information
so they can help farmers around the
world share best practices with one
another so there's a lot of socially
relevant things that can be done by
isolating the models you still can tap
into the big models that we have but the
data that you upload can be very
customized which means that the accuracy
of the translation model that you build
could be higher so education is another
one and we find a lot of educators I've
already got translated data data so
they're great candidates for doing a
specific translation model particularly
if you pick a specific domain of
education so when you are after you've
selected your project you arrive here
you can either add files for training
right away if you're just gonna just do
that you're not going to invite the
community or you can also invite your
community enters and co-owners the nice
thing about having co-owners is that
means more than one person is
responsible for using the system so
typically we we set up co-owners as
people who are sort of your committee
your group and your community that you
want to have be responsible for the
model but you can also invite
communities in a less trusted role to
just be reviewers and they can submit
transitions but they can't approve them
and I'll show you what that looks like
in a little bit so here's what I would
upload my data this one I'm actually
uploading a file for Spanish so that I
can go into the system for training and
I thought what I do here is pause and
talk about a little bit about what
parallel documents are most people don't
have a good grasp of this and they also
don't realize that they have a lot of
them
so for instance if I just hunt around
the Microsoft site so here's one that's
on discovering Internet Explorer 9
but we've also paid money to have it
translated into Spanish so this is a
truly parallel document has the exact
same content but what you can do is you
can upload them both and this is a
parallel file and a lot of times like
people say well do they have to be in
the same file they don't we actually
intentionally put them in separate file
because typically you don't put them in
the same file so one HTML page which is
one of the file formats that we support
can be mapped to another HTML page the
only thing is that the first part of the
name has to be the same so one of the
things I was telling you about more
tapping into the Microsoft models you do
that by selecting here it is on by
default that you can access our models
on the back end your small data combined
with it however if you're really looking
for something extremely custom you could
actually pick this off right and so you
don't actually have to use it we make it
an option but we do add it because it
does send an increase blue scores what's
most important is this tuning and
testing if you're doing a
domain-specific model you want to make
sure that the files that you upload for
tuning and testing accurately reflect
the domain that you're trying to build
so this particular file is one that's a
very much a representative sample if
this works sake for chemistry or
anthropology this file should be
targeted it should have data that's very
specific to that particular domain and
that's both for tuning and testing so
once I've drafted a training it shows up
in my overall heads-up display for this
particular training thing once it's
drafted I can then choose whether or not
to run it if it runs successfully it
will say succeeded if it doesn't it says
failed typically that's because they
don't have enough data in the system
don't worry just add more data it's it's
quite easy to fix once something has
been succeeded it can then be deployed
and once deployed your community can
then start working on it improving it
making it its function better so I had
to switch to Hmong I had didn't have a
Maya I didn't have data to build a Maya
and Spanish
translator so I have to switch to one of
the ones I do have to plug which is
Hmong and I it's interesting here to see
that how is the weather and you see it
translated here in Tamang I don't speak
Hmong either so don't worry about that
that's not the point of the slide but if
I go out to being you'll notice it's
different it's actually slightly
different and the reason is because in
our tool you'll get multiple different
types so for instance in this listing
the community has submitted three
different ways to say this sentence and
they're all right there's not one of
them that's wrong because they've all
put got a blue ribbon next one that
means some reviewer went in and said yep
these are all acceptable and the reason
for that is in different contexts a
sentence might mean different things and
so what we're trying to do is provide
all of the different possible options
that it could be but the one that
succeeded is is this one here at the top
so data really is the key to translation
quality you need to have a minimum of
ten thousand parallel sentences in order
for you to build a translation model
that's actually really not a lot of data
and if particularly if you are an
educator and you built all of these
websites you often have that data lying
around but you just don't realize it
books for instance we work a lot with
publishers you know they pay a lot of
money to translate their books and what
they'd like to do is be able to then
translate their online properties using
these very custom models and that works
extremely well and they have hundreds of
thousands even millions of sentences
available but you can access a system
through our API that I talked about
earlier HTTP soap Ajax in OData you can
embed the widget like we did in the Lake
Washington School District example that
I showed you earlier this is where you
can gather community inputs there but
you can also gather community inputs
from using the Microsoft translator hub
there's a UI where you saw them against
one another users can submit
translations there this goes into a
collaborative translation memory and
then we get 100% match at the runtime
the Train models come out and you get
parallel training data
this is and also an association we build
off your your target training data so
the community gets an immediate reward
they get immediate credit in a
leadership board we show who's leading
the charge and then they get immediate
validation and ranking and that was why
I was showing which ones three three
things were submitted the top one is the
one that gets the highest ranking and
validation so collaboration is the key
to vitality so data may be the key to
building the translation model
collaboration is really how you keep it
vibrant how you keep it evolving and so
you know what you want to do is you want
to get a lot of really good parallel
data that's from within a domain from
your community you can achieve the
higher quality by using Microsoft
stepping into Microsoft's Big Data
models and then the Microsoft translator
widget collects data also from your
community and in order to build the best
system possible you can use the
translator hub so I did the wrong thing
there there we go so I thought what I
would do is I wrap this up with a new
tool that we've just recently come out
with that's driven by the Microsoft
translator system this system is called
the your mobile travel companion and it
runs on any Windows mobile phone what it
allows you to do is you know Rick rash
it's a big Star Trek fan so I couldn't
help through gold liebelei go or no man
has gone before
so quite literally it does translation
of speech it even does like video it
does text and images which is really
incredible it uses OCR to take that in
and it uses automatic translation and
human dated so if you have your friends
they can actually help you as well they
can make corrections along the way so
friends and your social network can also
make corrections um it uses smarts it
knows where you are so for instance it
knows right now that I'm in Cancun and
so it operates differently here than it
would if I were in the United States so
it if I have my locator location turned
on on my phone it actually can rely on
that to tell me what's the location I'm
in in the context I'm in and it's been
implemented as a Windows Phone
application literally it could be speech
text
and they even the science and if you
come by the booth I have a demo fest
booth for both of these particular
projects so I invite you to come by and
check it out but it takes that video
speech and text sends it to the phone
and then it also interacts with Facebook
that Facebook uses our translator as
well and then through the translator it
comes out again in as video speech and
text this is important so if I take a
picture of a sign and I want to know how
it's pronounced in Chinese what I can do
is take that picture of that sign or
maybe the signs in Chinese but I want to
hear it in English because I don't speak
Chinese what I can do is I could say
output it to speech and then my phone
will literally say what the phrase is
that's on that particular sign so it's
quite handy to have when you're
traveling so what it looks like is this
when you load the system you come in and
it shows you a startup page there's a
keyboard camera voice so literally the
camera on your phone is where you can
capture images so it's asking you what
is the input that you're going to be
using and then over here is where you
actually select that which languages
that you want to translate between one
of the things really nice about this is
you can do just right away type
something in you know how are you como
esta if I have images I take a picture
of it immediately it overlays the text
right over there this is a case of where
I've gone I want text output so I've got
an overlay in English from Chinese which
I don't speak and then if I want I can
even speak into it and have it translate
so maybe I speak English and I want
someone to hear it in their language I
could speak into my phone and it would
speak it back out in the language that
they needed to hear in so one of the
most important things about this tool is
well we're not always connected to the
Internet and it can be very hard to want
to do this you know you may have more
connectivity when you grow more travel
like I do you don't want to pay the data
charges so it's quite easy to actually
download some of these phrase books to
your phone itself so that when you're
offline or even in airplane mode you can
still access all the functionality that
you've seen here so in this case I'm
actually downloading a French language
one and I'm going to come down
it's now but succeeded it's now in my
system but I want to view some of the
other ones that I've got so as you can
see I have five of them and my in my
phone that I can access and all of these
are available offline all the
functionality that I told you about is
available offline to users so this is
downloadable from the Windows Phone
Marketplace not just the English site
but also on our our site for Mexico so
you're free to go there and download it
and test it out it shipped earlier this
year are there any questions it's funny
because I had so many slides I were
thinking I'm gonna be over yes
yes gracias
what about the server I mean for example
my an a school that does not have any
connectivity or internet connection or
it's not as good as it should be sure
what what do you have options to work
offline you for the hub or for the
mobile full of hub
yeah the hub is not offline okay and you
do need to have connectivity at least
regularly the nice thing about it is
it's extremely fault tolerant because
it's built on Azure weave when we were
in Nepal the internet would drop out
like I wit would cycle up and down about
every I don't know I sometimes it was
every five minutes over other times it
was every half hour the thing is is the
system keeps your state so ie is very
good about keeping your state I'm sure
most other browsers are as well but we
were using IE in this particular case so
even though the internet had gone away
and the model had gone away the moment
that we were back online the people who
were doing reviews submitting
translations using the system were able
to pick up exactly where they left off
that they had no problem at all actually
just interacting with the system they
were get an error the moment that it
occurred they could resubmit and then it
would go through so state is maintained
within the browser by the way in which
we implemented the UI for this system ok
but that's for the hub but then if you
already have the information in the
server mm-hmm you can download a subset
to your phone you can for a classroom
for example yes absolutely no you can
build materials educational materials in
Mayan Spanish yes download it to the
phones
sure ok yeah fantastic yeah you want to
try it ok no you can't try it
hi I would like to ask about the
categories or domains are they like
built in or can they be modified for
example if I choose 220 in you category
I haven't seen I don't know the fields
to to add one more you you you can
request that we add another one in fact
this I'm glad you asked this question
because there's something I failed to
mention earlier in my talk so the
domains are presently fixed in the
system but you can request when there's
a link there to request it just below
the domain but in addition to that
there's also a link to request new
languages so even though there's 1,300
in there
these things actually can be changed in
addition for domain specific ones you
can further isolate it by on your own so
while the category list may be fixed for
when you start and maybe we haven't
added it yet what you can do is you can
actually there's a box directly below it
that allows you to type in your own
domain so we think these areas are very
at a very high level so for instance one
might I think one of them is sports
that's fine but sports is a very broad
thing right education is a very broad
thing it's too broad so what you can do
is you can further classify it by adding
something into that field that says ok
this is education but maybe it's going
to be about mathematics this is
education it's going to be about physics
so you can automatically with the system
right as you create the project perform
a sub classification directly in the UI
at the project's creation
they know they don't actually so the
question was for those of you who don't
know didn't here it is do the parallel
documents have to be sentence by
sentence we do have a sentence mapping
tool and taught inside of the system
because you know there's no way like
with mom the reason why there's so many
different translations for for one
single sentence is because and they're
all correct right all the reviewers had
gone through who selected them and said
they were all correct is that in
different contexts things are different
and the other thing is sometimes the way
in which you express something in one
language is ordered differently not just
within the sentence but even para
graphically and so what we try to do is
we try to match them up we have a
mapping algorithm to map between the
sentences by looking at individual words
that we know are accurately we have a
dictionary lookup and so then we can map
the sentence even if it appears before
or after to the appropriate translation
in the other language sorry to be so no
no it's fine
but what is it could you explain it
something very basic because I get this
question a lot what is the difference
between this kind of translator hub and
a typical dictionary word by word what's
the real breakthrough in in this kind of
technology well one of the things is
that it even in a book it remains fixed
that's the problem what we're trying to
do really ultimately and so I'm very
glad that you've asked this question is
is to try and capture this language that
it's not a moving target languages
living it's a very living thing and the
you know you can get these books provide
snapshots what they don't do is they you
know you have to do another revision and
it takes a long time for it to print to
another revision takes a long time to
print for an automatic translation
system that doesn't have there needs to
be no delay they can automatically be
fixed very quickly and so every time the
model is redeployed if you deploy it
yourself privately then it all the
changes that you made our resident
immediately in that private model
for shipping it in being that's that
takes some time they could they go
through a process that's a periodic
thing but for your private model that
you own yourself the changes are
instantaneous and so that evolution of
language can be easily updated all of
the time and maybe it's you know it
happens a little at a time it's also
very hard to do it as an undertaking is
a big thing it's much easier if your
community's making corrections as they
go and the other thing is you think
about it one person usually typically
creates her a couple of people usually
create dictionary lookups and and phrase
books but tapping into the community is
probably the best way to do it quickest
and keep it more accurate over time I
mean crowdsourcing is just really
ultimately the best way to go so that
that's I hope I answered your question
okay
okay well thank you very much each year
Microsoft Research hosts hundreds of
influential speakers from around the
world including leading scientists
renowned experts in technology book
authors and leading academics and makes
videos of these lectures freely
available